[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now this past
year wasn't just economic challenges
we saw harassment and violence rear its
ugly head
that's why in this past election the
stakes were high
not just for small business owners like
mine struggling to stay afloat
but it was high for our asian american
community
as we faced rising hate the stakes were
also high
for georgians of every background black
white
latinx lgbtq jewish and muslim
the stakes were high for all of us not
just across georgia but for
america for every community what did we
do
we got out there and we talked to our
neighbors we talked to our communities
and we reached across our state and
across the country
we became a broad coalition fighting for
new leadership to bring us out of this
crisis
and into a brighter future to once again
make our nation that beacon of hope that
my father and so many others turned to
for refuge
we busted our butts we knocked on doors
called voters
placed yard signs in front of businesses
and our homes
we wrote postcards and georgia you heard
our call
you answered by getting out the vote
like never before their turnout in the
aapi
latinx and black communities were
record-shattering
[Applause]
you showed the importance of voting and
why voting matters
yes protect the vote we elected joe
biden and kamala harris the first black
and asian-american
vice president and for the first time
in our states has and for the first time
in
28 years our state has elected
a democratic ticket
right here in gwinnett we flipped the
seventh district
we elected carolyn bordeaux and we sent
her to the state house
but we didn't stop there we continued
to fight we continued to talk to our
neighbors
we fought and we made we elected
georgia's first black senator reverend
rafael warno
we elected our first jewish senator john
ossoff
[Music]
we did that georgia we made the
difference
and now a hundred days later we see the
fruits
of our vote joe biden listened to us
he and his administration is putting our
country back
on track the american rescue plan has
already changed the course of the
pandemic in georgia
it's bringing financial help to families
that desperately need it
it's giving businesses like mine a shot
at success
and fulfilling the american dream more
and more people are getting vaccinated
every day
and we see our communities once again
start to thrive
but on top of all of that the first 100
days of the biden administration
have shown that we have true moral
leadership in the white house again
it was a little over a month ago when
six asian american women were murdered
in attacks on asian-owned businesses
here in atlanta
our community was devastated we were
angry we were scared
but through strong moral leadership joe
biden and kamla harris
stopped what they were doing and they
came down to atlanta and
met with the leaders of our community
they shared in our grief they listened
to our concerns
they committed to fighting the rising
hatred against our community
and all communities across the country
that is real leadership
[Music]
life is full of challenges and sometimes
the odds are stacked against you
the odds were stacked against my parents
before they came to america
the odds were stacked against my
business when the pandemic hit
but we made it through and with this
administration things are looking up
again
the odds were against us here in georgia
during the election
but with hard work and perseverance we
did
what many thought we couldn't and it's
only been 100 days but joe biden's
presidency
has already begun to lift us up it has
made our community
safer healthier and stronger
it has restored faith in our country
faith in the united states of america
that we will once again
be the shining example for all the world
to see
i cannot wait to see what the next
hundred days will bring us
i have faith that we have great things
in store for our nation
so thank you president biden thank you
georgia
i love you and now it is my great honor
to welcome back to the state of georgia
president joe biden
and the first lady dr joe biden
[Music]
here
[Music]
disappointment was my closer friend
and you know he never showed his face
[Applause]
[Music]
again
[Music]
wow what a great crowd thanks for coming
thank you long joe and i had the chance
to see our friends
we just saw them president and former
first lady carter
[Music]
and they are such a powerful reminder
that serving our country isn't limited
to the office you hold
the carters continue their work making
our country
stronger every day and we are grateful
and honored for their friendship
and wow i'm so glad to be with all of
you
thank you for being here
from columbus to albany macon to atlanta
i've always felt so at home here
and i'm especially excited to be back
in the state that sent raphael warnock
and john
ossoff to the senate
[Music]
[Applause]
and you know georgia we could not have
passed the american rescue
plan without you
[Music]
in some ways it's hard to believe that
it's already been
100 days back
in dc we're still getting to know our
new home
figuring out where the light switches
are and remembering to use
coasters on the historic furniture
but in other ways we've packed so much
into the time that's just flown by
i've already traveled to schools and
community colleges across the country
visited vaccine sites and military bases
and charted the course for our joining
forces
initiative so thank you to all the
military who are here
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's just my office across the
administration we've made historic
progress
all because of the historic leadership
of my husband
you hear them honking their horns where
you joke
and what drew me to joe all those years
ago
was his fortitude beneath his kindness
his charm and good humor
was a man of action who always kept his
promises
did the necessary work and showed
up when it mattered and
and that's why i have always believed
that he would be the president that we
need
in the first 100 days of this
administration
america is seeing the true character
of the person that i have known for so
long
whose heart is big enough to comfort the
families
of more than 500 000 lost
whose vision is ambitious enough to make
the investment
of a generation whose determination is
strong enough
to bring americans from all walks of
life together
whose commitment is steadfast enough to
not only keep his promises
but surpass them
joe is a man for this moment
and with his leadership we
are rising
i couldn't be more proud of what he's
done in just
100 days or more hopeful
of what we are going to do next
please help me in welcoming my husband
the president of the united states joe
[Applause]
[Music]
biden
[Music]
[Music]
hello georgia in the other county back
there
i love you a lot of folks out here
tonight
well i'm ready to go home because she
never says that to me at home
this is worth the trip hearing that
i am jill's husband is obvious to
everybody
i never get introduced to she's my wife
i'm her husband
and uh you know uh i'm proud to be
you know uh i want to thank
long time tran for being with us tonight
his story is a story of an entire
generation but it's a story that goes
back many generations
not just in south vietnam and in asia
writ large
but all over the world and america
it's the reason why we're strong we are
the most diverse democracy in the world
and we do there's not a single thing
i mean this from the bottom of my heart
there's not a single thing
we can't do when we do it together so
thank you all
and i want to thank my friend
keisha lance bottoms and thanks to
democratic members of congress
senator osophen warnock representative
sanford bishop and old friend hank
johnson
and lucy mcbath and look i want to make
sure representative williams is here i
thought i saw her
a moment ago there you are
okay and and representative carolyn
bordeaux
you know we need to work and help them
keep their
seats it's important we run the first
round but there's more coming up
and my good friend and dnc chair jamie
harrison from south carolina
and stacey abrams it can be anything she
wants to be from whatever she chooses to
president
i want to thank you stacy for empowering
the people to vote
and to make their voices heard you've
been amazing
and most of all i want to thank you the
people of georgia
now
[Applause]
folks
georgia was uh a hundred days ago today
when i was inaugurated
on the steps of the united states
capitol to be your president
and i was looking forward to coming back
and seeing these guys
i agree with you i'm working on a man
give me another
five days
folks you all know what they're talking
about
there should be no private prisons
period
none period that's what they're talking
about
private detention centers they should
not exist
and we are working to close all of them
so folks look
thank you all right thank you
all right okay let him go no no
i promise you the only things that keep
me from doing that is you keep moving
i promise you
thank you folks
look i spent 100 days
since i first sat at my desk in the oval
office
and went to work for you and the
american people i want to thank
you i want to thank the american people
because i think we've gotten a lot done
i promised even before i was sworn in
that i would get in my first hundred
days
a hundred million covert vaccine shots
in people's arms
we've lost over 550 000 americans
well we delivered over 220 million
coveted shots in the first hundred days
we've vastly expanded access
we've got 100 million doses of vaccine
enough for
every single american and we've done it
by getting vaccines to some
40 000 pharmacies across the country 700
community centers
and now now everyone
over the age of 16 is now eligible to
get vaccinated right away
so please do it get vaccinated now
now now now
[Music]
and we promise to deliver emergency
relief to the millions
of americans who are in financial
distress
and i might add through no fault of
their own
so we got out 1 400 checks to the
american people
and we kept that promise 85 of the
households in america
have gotten those checks we've already
sent out more than 160 million
checks out the door and i want to stop
here
and give thanks to both your senators
senators
ossoff and warnock for making it happen
because those two votes
had we not come back and you elected
them those two votes
made the difference it passed by a
single vote
and that means we owe special thanks to
the people of georgia
because of you the rest of the world
because of your two senators the rest of
america
was able to get the help they got so far
the american rescue plan would not have
passed
so much have we gotten done like getting
checks to people probably would not have
happened
so if you ever wonder if elections make
a difference
just remember what you did here in
georgia when you elected ossoff and
warnock
you begin to change the environment
look because of you we passed one of the
most consequential rescue bills
in american history so what to do
you know what did you do what would you
do with your vote here in georgia well
you changed america you began to change
america
and you're helping us prove that
democracy
democracy can still deliver for the
people
look i want to thank you for all of that
all america wants to thank you
because here's what we mean by
delivering for the people
we created in the first hundred days one
million
three hundred thousand new jobs one
million three hundred thousand jobs
in 100 days that's more june new jobs in
the first hundred days of any president
in history folks because of you
and we're here just a few more things
that we needed we provided food
nutrition assistance
for children and families so they don't
go hungry rental assistance to keep
people from being evicted from their
homes
loans to small businesses like long to
keep people
to keep them open and people employed we
made
georgia eligible to expand medicaid
which means
another 500 000 georgians can be covered
[Music]
excuse me folks health care
should be a right not a privilege in
america
and here's the thing i'm most proud of
we are on track to cut child poverty in
half
this year by having passed the child tax
credit
now but as much as we've done
we got a lot more to do that's why i
propose the american jobs plan
it is it's a once in a generation
investment in america
it's the biggest jobs plan in this
country since world
war ii and here's what it does it
creates jobs rebuilding modernizing our
roads
our highways our bridges our porch our
airports
it will provide clean drinking water for
every american
there are 10 million homes in america
and there are 40 400 000 schools and day
care centers
that have lead pipes where drinking the
water
is a danger we're going to replace 100
of those nations lead pipes and service
lines so
every child can have a turn at the
faucet and know what they're drinking
is clean water folks we're going to
provide reliable high-speed internet
everywhere in america including
rural america 15 of georgia households
do not have internet at all
we're going to change that those
infrastructure projects are going to
create
millions of good paying jobs just
installing them
we also know that 2 million women 2
million women have dropped out of the
workforce during this pandemic
2 million because too often they have to
choose
between whether or not they can get care
for their child
and their family or go to work
in the 21st century infrastructure isn't
just steel and concrete
it's people and it's time we start
paying
people who come to our homes and care
for people
that love them and going to take care of
them
and folks you know a lot of people
talk about climate they forget to
mention the most important word
i made a promise when i was down here
running that
i would in fact immediately rejoin the
paris climate accord
on day one which we did and i would have
in the first hundred days
a climate summit here in america
inviting all the world's polluters and
all the world's emitters
including the biggest nations in the
world
and they came everyone from russia to
china to the european union down india
all of them and you know what what came
across
every single one of those countries
whether they're going to meet their
obligations or not
is finally understanding that taking
care of saving the planet
is going to create millions of good
paying jobs
millions of good-paying jobs we're going
to put
engineers and construction workers
electricians
electrical workers building efficient
buildings and homes we're going to
install 500
000 charging stations along the highways
we're going to rebuild
and there's no reason why the blades for
windmills turbines
can't be built in pittsburgh instead of
beijing
there's no reason there's no reason
where american workers can't lead the
world in the production of electric
vehicles and the batteries that
propel them we can do what we need to do
in saving the planet and yet create
millions of good paying jobs
folks and with all the investments in
the american jobs plan
here's what we're going to do we're
going to buy america
let me explain what that means you know
there
is not a violation of any trade
agreement every tax dollar
that we in fact get for construction of
anything
is going to go to be used to buy
american products
made in america that create american
jobs that's the way it should be
because look folks wall street didn't
build this country
you did the middle class did and unions
built the middle class
and here's one final thing i want to
mention about the american jobs plan
we got 500 we got 5 billion investment
in that plan for community violence
intervention
there's a lot of work we have to do a
lot of work we have to do
and i want you to know who's responsible
for that
mayor keisha bottoms keisha lance
bottoms
but folks we not only have to invest in
america we need to invest in our
families
we need to invest in things our families
care about and need the most
that's why the american family plan does
four things
and we pay for it all one without
raising the deficit
it adds four years more guaranteed
public education in america
if we were building on our education
system start today like we did in the
last century did anybody think we'd say
12 years of education is enough
to compete and win the competition in
the 21st century
i don't think so so when we did that
last century it made america the best
educated best prepared nation in the
world
but the rest of the world has called up
to us now so my plan
provides a universal preschool for every
three and four-year-old in america
everyone that's a game changer it's a
game changer
and also provides two years of free
community college
that's a game changer as well jill is a
community college
professor still teaching she constantly
says
joe community colleges can change the
lives of students
as she always say look any country that
educates us
is going to out compete us she'll be
leading one of these efforts as well
look one more thing we've got some great
historical black universities and
colleges in georgia
and we're going to be investing them and
increa investing in them and increasing
pell grants they don't have
they don't have the back the all the
the money that is comes from the large
universities
but their students are as competent to
do anything in the future as anyone else
but here's the deal we're going to
provide
up to 47 billion over 10 years to
increase their capacity
to do everything but deal with you know
cyber security all those things where
the jobs of the future are
the second thing we're going to do
provide quality affordable child care
you know i know i was a single dad for
five years
when my wife and daughter got killed
right after i got elected the united
states senate as a 29 year old kid
what happened was i was lucky i had a
daughter i had two boys survived my
daughter and wife were killed
but my two boys survived and fortunately
for me i had an incredible family
my sister my brother and my mother and
father
they basically moved in and helped me
raise my kids because although i was a
senator
i was listening to the poor senator in
history but not history but in the
years i was there i couldn't afford
the cost of daycare i couldn't have
forced the cost of child care
but i had them i don't know how i would
have done it without them
so understand how important child care
can be under my plan
most folks won't pay more than seven
percent of their income for child
care as a max and the folks who need it
the most and can't afford it all
won't have to spend a dime that's
important
and america third thing is american
family plan will finally provide
up to 12 weeks of paid family and
medical leave
no one no one should have to choose
between a job and a paycheck or taking
care of themselves
a loved one a parent or a spouse or a
child
and fourth american family plan puts
money directly into the pockets of
millions of families
the american rescue plan we passed we
passed the child credit
we're going to expand that child credit
to families for
another five years families with two
kids that will mean that as much as
7 200 will go into their pockets every
year
georgia this is a tax cut for more than
2 million families in georgia we're
cutting taxes for people
by a tax credit and we left more than
170
000 children out of poverty right here
in america
and cut child poverty this year in half
folks so how are we going to pay for all
this
well with tax cuts for the middle class
and working class families how are we
going to pay for that
well it's real simple it's about time
the very wealthy and corporations start
paying their fair share
it's about time
as simple as that and folks i'm not
going to bore you the details but i
promise you
no one making under 400 000
a year is going to pay a single
additional penny
in tax no one as i said last night
the middle class and working people of
this country are already paying enough
in taxes
it's time for the richest one percent of
americans and corporate americans start
to do their part
let me just give you a simple fact last
year for example
55 of our largest corporations in
america
paid zero dollars in federal tax zero
and they made 40 billion dollars
not a penny in tax folks if in fact
we had a minimum book tax for
corporations
for the fortune just the fortune 500
companies just a minimum tax
of 15 about all you'd sign up for 15
tax right now if in fact with just 15
we'd raise 230
billion dollars pay for all this
so folks i'm not trying to punish anyone
but we've got to make corporations
making 40 billion paying
zero is just not right something's
seriously wrong here georgia i think a
lot of you know i ran for president
saying we had to heal the soul of this
nation
that's what we have to do and the
conviction of george floyd's murderer
is now our opportunity to make some real
progress to restore
the soul of this country and we can do
it
we can act rational police reform we can
root out systemic racism in our criminal
justice system
and with real plans i
outline today we have a real chance to
deliver
real equity across the board to everyone
black white latino asian american good
jobs good schools affordable housing
clean air clean water
look being able to generate wealth and
pass it down through generations
is how most folks got there
but it beans yeah how did most of the
middle class folks you know
who are caucasian or white how'd they
make well
they were able to get enough money to
buy a home and they built equity in that
home
and they built that grenade at home they
passed it on and they passed it on and
that's how you build wealth
well we're going to make sure that
african americans
as well as make sure the latinos and
asian americans are able to build that
kind of wealth
look when the vice president and i were
in atlanta last month
we met with leaders of the africa of the
asian american community in georgia
following the mass shootings here in
atlanta
it was a raw and powerful meeting and a
very emotional moment
and some criticized me for speaking out
nationally about that hate crime
some criticized me for saying how ugly
and sinister it was
well since then because of the two
senators you sent
among others the united states senate
passed the covet 19 hate crimes act
protect
asian americans and pacific islanders
from the vicious hate crimes
we've seen too often too long in the
past 94 to 1.
so don't tell me we can't make progress
it's a first step we have a lot more to
do
you know that's right if we are
too truly he'll hear the soul of america
we need to project
that sacred right and protect it to vote
you know in this
state of dr king and john lewis you know
how precious and how
precarious the right to vote is in
november and then again in january
your vote changed the world not just
north of the world but instead of
celebrating that it's being attacked
more people voted for president
in 2020 than any time in american
history ever
and they did it in the middle of a
pandemic
and what you've seen what's happened
here in georgia
with your state's laws it's just wrong
wrong and it's why we have to pass the
voting rights protection laws
coming through the congress right now
h.r 1 and the john lewis voting rights
act both should be passed
now so folks
it's only been 100 days but i have to
tell you
i've never been more optimistic about
the future in america america's on the
move again
we're choosing hope over fear truth over
lies
light over darkness and we're working
we're working again we're dreaming again
we're discovering again
and we're leading the world again and
you're proving
democracy can deliver for the people we
just need to remember
who we are we are the united states of
america
and there's nothing nothing nothing we
cannot do
if we do it together so let's stay
together
god bless you all may god protect our
troops thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
georgia
i see two guys in the back i want to
come up here
[Music]
[Music]
warnock
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
looking for my mask i'm in trouble
[Music]
[Music]
i can stand up and face
oh georgia we need you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and you know he never showed his face
again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
arms around i can stand up
and face
[Music]
myself
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's been a long long time
[Music]
wait a minute
[Music]
you might recall
[Music]
[Music]
you told me
[Music]
wait a minute
[Music]
um
come on
[Music]
we gonna
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
what's up
hey
oh
[Music]
oh
he's still standing right there he's
still standing right there
present
[Music]
okay i'll make a note of that for next
time we're always trying to improve a
little bit more would have been helpful
okay yeah
really appreciate you
yeah i'm a little you know i can't see
anything on my right side oh gosh
i hope we get some refs and some
sunscreen thank you so much
thank you all right guys no problem
oh
[Music]
he's not living alone
oh
[Music]
it's about uh jails and i think
you know how jails operated by private
companies about funny
i think that's that's what i understand
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
you want to put it down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they're gone
this is going for lunch for dinner
airport